macht man das also leute mit dem man
nichts zu tun hat will man über dawson
und hecken warum sich damit ist oder so
also ich verstehe es nicht ganz den
großen straftat die wird bestraft mit
bis zu drei jahren freiheitsentzug oder
einer geldstrafe so ist das
es geht sondern ist willkommen zu einer
neuen folge heute haben wir ein relativ
spannendes und interessantes thema und
zwar scheint es jetzt so weit zu sein
dass diese ganze hetzerei und jedoch
scheiße aber wirklich auf ihn
zurückfällt der dass die ganze zeit
gemacht hat und zwar als man weiß nicht
was an den gerüchten dran ist
aber man munkelt momentan genauso uns
auf baustellen zwar genau heute mit
wegen und ich erkläre mich bin ich bin
der armada kann dann schreibt man
schnell noch tätig war hat mich einfach
nicht anfreunden hierbei dialog
ich habe eine waffe noch brauchst du
nicht hätten alle übrigen ich hab keinen
youtuber mehr danken gespielt wie ich
denke das können wir heute als eine
folge erklärt richtig passiert aber als
aller erstes mal ja einer der bekannt
war dafür zu den osten
ich sage es mal keiner weil nicht klar
ist ob die geschichte wahr ist soll
jetzt angeblich eine anzeige bekommen
haben und jetzt erstmal im internet sind
ja also falls die geschichte stimmt
wohlgemerkt falls dies stimmt dass man
weiß es nicht weil irgendwie einer der
ihm nahesteht hat uns erzählt dass kann
sein ist einfach scheiße labert aber ich
hoffe jetzt einfach mal dass die
geschichte stimmt und der wirkliche gau
eine strafe bekommen hat weil er hatte
während schon geredet hatten mich schon
wieder los und max kdfb das weiß das und
das kann es einfach nicht sein irgendwie
also irgendwann ist dann auch mal
schluss und ich hoffe wirklich jetzt
nicht aus sadismus sondern einfach aus
dem gerechtigkeitssinn heraus dass er
seine strafe bekommen hat und jetzt
wirklich im internat ist so wie es heißt
und von da erst mal weg ist von allen
ddos möglichkeiten werde mich ganz gut
für die minecraft community weil sowas
aber ich scheiße ich sag mal so die
ganzen leute die ja die russen haben
eigentlich in mit der ganzen sache
einfach sozusagen die deutsche minecraft
community einfach so stolz dass ich
jetzt mal man kann das doch kein ja da
hört mich man kann auf keinen deutschen
server mehr gehen ohne die antwort
and they called the date of spain lief
oder tigers oder wann was das one oder
die das ergibt einfach
dieser anteil wird zeige ich habe
zweifel hier hinten an der von ah danke
ich da mal kurz nach ja ja gut ich mal
woanders hin
leute ich muss jetzt einfach mal ganz
klar meine meinung sagen ich habe
keinerlei respekt für leute die sowas
machen
ich hab ne der person keine probleme
gehabt keine irgendwie missverständnis
hat er sowieso nichts getan und wenn die
dann ankommt die frechheit besitzt mich
anzugreifen ist eine straftat drei
paragraf 303b strafgesetzbuch absatz
einfach ist das thema ja ich bin's ich
bin es so elegante straftat die wird der
wird bestraft mit sechs monaten bis drei
jahren freiheitsentzug oder einer
geldstrafe mit bis zu drei jahren
freiheitsentzug oder einer geldstrafe so
ist das und ja es ist kein kinderspiel
ist computersabotage straftaten
deutschland was man dazu noch sagen kann
es wenn er zum beispiel server von
gewissen webseiten oder generell andere
rootserver angreift dann kann es sogar
noch bis zu zehn jahre gehen genau dann
ist es dann ist es nämlich dann ist es
gewerblich und dann muss er ich weiß
etwas gewerbliches aber das ist dann
schon gravierender schaden und daher das
ist daten schaden weil die daten wenn ja
auch gespeichert und wenn datenverlust
auf kompromisse kennt werner schade ich
glaube der gibson zwei leute erschreckt
sondersatz der besagt dass in dem fall
wenn ein materieller schaden entsteht
dann die strafe auf sich auf mindestens
sechs monate bis zehn jahre beläuft also
ist kein kinderspiel
und wer dann war da einige die leute
haben die leute haben segler gering weil
die anonymität im internet
die haben sich dann in tschanter nicht
benutzten geflogen jetzt machen wir
vielleicht auch von kurzen quer zu reden
die leute haben sich immer gefreut über
die anonymität im internet
sie können alles machen weil jetzt ewig
die in eurogoals aber ich hoffe mal
wirklich das jetzt einfach mal klar
gezeigt wird und noch mal gezeigt oder
so was nicht geht weil es kann nicht
sein dass das straftaten
fortwährend begangen werden und die
nicht geahndet werden ich hoffe wirklich
einfach im sinne der ganzen community
und auch gewisse machen war es nach dem
sinn des rechtsstaats dass da
entsprechende maßnahmen ergriffen wurden
wie seht ihr das denn während du wirst
ja auch genau das was ich echt lustig
fanden jemand hat und das video
geschrieben
die lachse [ __ ] ich habe
geschrieben richtig und der typ der das
video gemacht hat ich nenne jetzt mal
nicht den namen vielleicht findet ihr
dass er selber heraus der typ der das
video gemacht hat und in voll hansa
lachs ist genau das hat sogar ich hab
mir hat unter geschrieben wie wichtig er
hat einfach mein kommentar das ist wer
wie alle zu würde ich jetzt mal bushido
als werde emery wo sie durchsetzt
irgendwie beleidigen entschieden die
like das dann einfach wieder von sap für
das kann man ja aber so allein im haus
werden im haus dass einer der hand hält
mit einem hertha need help also ich sag
mal so ich hoffe einfach mal dass der
sozusagen weg ist dann keine ahnung sind
ja auch andere leute die angegriffen
worden wie zum beispiel jetzt celtics
oder killer pvp aus meinem ex halb klar
die haben ja gestimmt und sind dadurch
immer ausgeträumt
aber wenn sie mal irgendjemanden aus der
elektrochemie lieder an getötet haben
nimmt in nc dann sind ihre kleinen
besser nämlich zurückgegangen im relax
oder aus dem bottich getötet leute so
macht jeder mensch der häufigster im
kopf ist weiß dass es nicht korrekt ist
und das ist eine straftat ist und dass
leute die das machen einfach bestraft
werden müssen da kann mir keine jetzt um
kommen und sagen dass es a sie ist es
ist einfach eine straftat leute und das
muss bestraft wer in der welt draußen
ist asien statt space
warum macht man das also leute mit dem
man nichts zu tun hat wie man dawson und
hecken warum sich cool ist oder so also
ich verstehe es nicht ganz versteht die
logik dahinter nicht
sagen der bogen der [ __ ] ja das ist
meine mutter wechsel darauf zehn jahren
ja genau darauf zu warten jetzt ich bin
dort während es dort ja genau wir haben
uns auch mit über verloren
alle die noch wissen will warum das
passiert ist hat natürlich seid ihr ja
ich kann das ganze mal kurz verlesen
dazu sagte dazu sage ich noch ich habe
mir immer gesagt wäre höher auf großen
youtuber nachzuziehen
wenn die aufnehmen oder stream aber
entlassen jetzt also ich war in die welt
was man gestern hätte simon eigenen also
hat sie mal wieder angefangen zu tun und
bisher natürlich auch fan von ihm
also ich zumindest ich bin ja selber bin
danach getan weil ich mitspielen wollte
so dann ich war in genau dem fucking
team was getötet hat ist fakt einfach ab
es ist ein faktenblatt also es war bloß
team
sie sind dann halt zu gelb gereicht die
ganze zeit umgeht war halt das team wo
simon banks
dennoch wenn du die pixar war alles gut
und ich glaube der gummi gummi hd die
ware nach halt im team gelb mein team
ist einfach jedes mal auf geld gegangen
ich schreibe in den chat wird auf gelb
zu gehen geht auch auf die anderen roten
und rot grün
so druckt ihn nicht die gehen einfach
weiterhin ich denke ok geil bad in der
baseball die base juckt mich nicht der
kampf dann kommt gelb zu uns wir töten
die ich gehe in die mitte georg roth was
macht das andere team
also mein team geht natürlich weiterhin
auf gelb rot geht natürlich auch noch
auf geld zerstört das bett die man
springt im stream runter und weil das
macht ja gar keinen spaß wenn die dann
ein ganzes team da tagen erlebt man auch
die lust daran ich lebte hören dann
später wieder nach weil ja kann man
warte warte warte also genau dann haben
sie halten im web gesucht wo halt nur
ihr team gingen an
das team spielen kann dann dachte okay
kommt da kannst du dann mitspielen weil
die wollen ja auch andere also ein
anderes team spielen und ich war eh solo
und natürlich wurde mir dann vorgeworfen
recht ausnutzen ist es einfach normal
dass bei einem stream 99,9 prozent der
leute versuchen nachzuziehen
am mir keiner erzählen dass das recht
ausnutzen ist und nur weil mein youtuber
ist davon trotzdem nach cernys auch
keine rede ist auch keine re gehört du
hattest du nicht mehr freundes ist denn
das aber im plural wie genau genau ich
habe ihm die lobby gesehen bin dadurch
nach getarnt also ist es einfach so dass
ungespielt ein krasses gewicht hat
seinen worten custos gewicht bei der gay
community war auch bei nick so der da
oben gespielt mal geschüttelt hat in der
zeit als lobby der ton gespielt als
nervend empfunden hat das den mods
gesagt und schon war der youtuber status
von von liebe leben also von karl weg ja
nicht sein
es geht hier ja nicht sagen dass
irgendwie ob saudi man at oder bei marko
ist auch gerade abgeschlossen also leute
ich wollte man sich einfach noch kurz
und den anderen mitteilen
wie gesagt ich hoffe dass da jetzt an
gerechtigkeit geschaffen wurde und jetzt
könnt ihr gerne daumen da lasse
natürlich gefallen hat oder eure meinung
dazu die kommentare schreibe ich auch
sehr interessieren ja ich hoffe wir man
sachlich genug für euch und dann sehen
uns beim nächsten jahr wieder während
logos in der beschreibung
haut rein abonniert mich